DirecTV is launching dog TV yeah that's
a television channel for your dog so
that you know people leave the radio on
when they go out or they leave the TV on
for their dog but now it is 24-hour
programming for your dog and we've got a
little sneak peek of it
Oh
Oh
okay so that clip obviously is mainly
for Buddhist dogs obviously yeah I like
how it was all dogs and then suddenly a
stingray yeah got in there I don't know
how that happened so yeah this is you
know dogs like to watch stingrays oh my
god did you know that Club stingrays um
so yes this is an actual television
channel that will be for dogs I don't
know how they're going to get people to
advertise on it but that's a whole other
situation we get a month free then you
have to pay for it ninety nine oh wait a
minute this is this completely crazy I
know we have this thing as as humans but
I think it's particularly the Americans
that we love to put human emotions on
our dogs and we think that they're
thinking the same things we're thinking
about but their animals aren't they do
they need TV shows I wouldn't put this
on for my fictitious dog but I would
watch it 24 hours a day
I mean Bo is very much like you says
like the Dow of dog yeah kind of like
that you know the whole vibe but I think
it's so stupid
but it's for people who put their and no
offense I don't know if this includes
either you but people who put their dogs
in like buggies and you know who say
like it's Sunday mommy know about these
big white German Shepherd what about
these people that walk their cats have
you ever seen them I got a guy that
lives near me now doesn't seem walking
my cat oh you walk your cat what do you
know are you doing I don't actually walk
him but one of them he's he he's an
indoor cat but he can scale a six and a
half foot wall and I don't want him to
get out of the yard so I have him in a
harness if he wants to go outside or
other cat just goes outside he you know
eat some grass right with gold but I
would never I would never take him out
front like walking down Melrose because
it's impossible I've tried it it really
is this just like some Network executive
came up with this idea and DirecTV said
let's do the dog funny because I know
said executive at DirecTV and I need to
put a phone call in town I'm not gonna
name any names uh I think they're trying
to go on and look the animals and pets
are a billion dollar industry even just
in America alone so we all like to put
our dogs and carriers get their nails
painted by them crazy things that they
probably don't need if diving
right exactly little barrettes and stuff
but don't we understand that dogs a are
pretty much color blind B they're all
sensory based I'm sure they can sort of
see the TV I play little videos of like
dogs barking to see if my dog she gets
up she looks at the screen and then like
after a few seconds she's she goes lays
back down so it's like they can't smell
them they can't touch them they can't
feel them so I'm like what's the point
I'm gonna pay five nine you know $4.99
five bucks six bucks or whatever a month
for this I don't think it's gonna go and
I really you know how do we know the dog
just put on the television the dogs can
watch whatever is on TV isn't this a
little bit like you guys remember baby
Mozart that was really hot for like a
couple years and they said well if you
play Mozart for the babies it's gonna
make their brains do other and then and
you have something ruin in that belly in
the oven and I we play some classical
music sometimes we go to bed but I
haven't done any of the baby mom and you
can't you can't feel the baby going to I
like that Beethoven they say that if you
play it before and then you play it when
they're born they sort of stop and I'm
like really no the harpsichord yeah
right agnostic is gonna throw some
papers at me like look what I composed
in the room right he'll be a tortured
artist that's what he'll be at the end
just like Mozart
I wonder if because like you said it is
a huge industry people treat their pets
like they're their children and I know
and we all cannot everybody does and and
babysitters when I was growing up was
Disney Channel Nickelodeon HBO and
they're like well hey if it worked for
me and I turned out okay I don't think
you know why mine was like you had to
wait for you damn cartoons for three
hours on Saturday morning that's what
you have that's before cable getting up
they were they were on at like 7:00 in
the morning right but that's not saying
they were only on for a few hours you
only got cartoons like Oh like on
Saturday mornings no later you know yeah
it was yeah yeah right would you would
you five dollars a month would you get
in on this I mean my dog I look I have a
television and I have a dog
they've never seen my dog pay any
attention to the television and dogs
bark on TV sometimes and she does she's
not an idiot she knows it's a TV so it's
really for idiot dog I'm saying they
can't smell anything they can't touch
him it's not it's not three-dimensional
it's like what's the point is harder
than that and as you said they are color
blind you know they don't have rods and
cones so that changes their their visual
perception you know remember that
episode of The Simpsons where they said
they'd do it out of the dogs out of
Santa's little helpers eyes so you can
see what he's seeing and it's all this
mumbled and the roar do ya matter and it
and it worries me because people already
are you know a lot of people are lazy
with their dogs and I think I'll just
put the TV on I'll come back on Tuesday
Yeah right exactly I know plenty of
people who put on TV or the radio when
they leave the house anyways for their
pets yeah okay great yeah I mean the dog
that's why I don't want a for another
bar yeah